eu fui criada como um menino
os meus pais tinham planos distintos pra
mim porque quando eu cheguei eu esperava
o recape e durante muito tempo
essa foi a tônica da minha vida até eu
me chocam meu filho acha que ele era bem
gato né fala aí
isso foi uma coisa que me definiu muito
e permaneceu durante muito tempo na
minha vida é até os 20 anos - as pessoas
me perguntavam se era homem ou mulher
mas a verdade é que isso lhe foi
conveniente durante muito tempo era mais
seguro feminino era mais confortável
feminino principalmente porque na
passagem entre a infância ea
adolescência e que o corpo passa a ter
uma forma de mulher eu sofri abuso mais
de 1 e por homens e alguns de confiança
isso obviamente uma com minha vida
imensamente eu acho que no meu caminho
de busca
eu tive dois grandes caminhos duas
grandes vertentes a primeira foi me
autorizar a ser mulher feminina
apesar da dor apesar dos recados
apesar da prática ser masculino isso é
muito recente
esse foi um trabalho construído um
trabalho praticado ser mulher mas ao
mesmo tempo em que eu fui pesquisar o
que era ser mulher porque eu não sabia
eu encontrei o outro lado que foi aí sim
algo que inaugurou na minha vida ao
universo de possibilidades que foi
entender o que acontece do lado de lá
o que eu percebi é que tem pouco diálogo
poucas possibilidades de a gente se
encontrar porque a gente está se
distanciando cada vez mais existir
o movimento feminista eu sou feminista
fique bem claro
mas a gente de alguma forma a gente se
em um pau liderou as mulheres nos ímpar
alterado adoro empoderamento
mas talvez até porque quem paga o melhor
eu acho incrível né só uma talvez numa
um site em alta aqui quer dizer se eu
acho que a gente teve que fazer esse
movimento a gente continua tendo que vai
pagar pelas nossas coisas que a gente
fez isso é só no frame do machismo e
valeu a pena continua valendo apenas
diferenças são grandes ainda a gente
sabe disso mas o fato é que acho que de
alguma forma a gente se distanciou e não
está incluindo os homens na conversa
o fato é que assim o que eu percebo é
que a gente está numa situação que está
causando dor pra todo mundo ea minha
proposta foi começar a divulgar
sistematicamente o que eu aprendi a
respeito não só do feminino pra mim no
meu contexto como do masculino para que
a gente comece a quebrar essas barreiras
entrar num diálogo que torne as
possibilidades mais amplas para todos
não sei se vocês sentem também essa
diferença nós mulheres a gente ficou
super independente a gente está indo
atrás das coisas eu não preciso mais os
caras
eu ia a gente está sentindo que eles
estão recuando e não o que a gente
precisa não é disso é uma movimentação
que beneficie todo mundo e tem a ver com
a popularidade da energias masculina e
feminina porque energia e por que a
popularidade energia porque todo mundo
tem
as duas se a gente fosse falar de
energia feminina e masculina
todo mundo homens e mulheres temos as
duas ea gente pode cultivar exercitar
praticar as duas
isso a gente está falando de relações de
se relacionar
independente de com quem seja seja seu
marido e seu filho seu chefe
seu companheiro seu parceiro de trabalho
seu pai seu irmão
a gente precisa entender que se a gente
tem dois pólos no mesmo lugar da fao
então quando a gente está falando de
polaridade a gente está falando de um
lado ocupa um pólo e outro ocupa o outro
pólo para que as coisas funcionem e
circulem adequadamente lado feminino
porque a gente tem emoção a intuição a
criatividade empatia ajuda cura
acolher receber e colaborar melhorar
isso está no feminino na energia
feminina
o feminino ele traz as cores sons a
textura às a a dança o movimento a
fluidez o rio que corre feminino é o não
forma feminino é o que sempre muda a
gente tem no feminino a radiância da
força vital da criação no núcleo central
do feminino
a gente tem a vida vamos ver o que
acontece nos pólos
a gente tem a forma masculina aborda a
contenção
o limite o risco a direção à condução
mostra o mundo masculino é o que mostra
o mundo
não é à toa que quando a gente é pequena
as meninas principalmente a gente sonha
com um cara que chega num cavalo bota
gente no cavalo e leva para um mundo
desconhecido de felicidade é a gente
sonha unicórnios e teto
hoje em dia eu experimento muito isso
pelo saudoso bené então entrou no carro
cara fala que a mágoa produziram leva
pra isso
nem sempre tem cara de felipe mas ele
está levando profundo né eu só pergunto
eu só quero uma vez ele conseguiu
caminho sugerido pelo ex vai mas vai com
fé eu vou aqui atrás
no masculino a gente tem a consciência a
presença imagine uma montanha a
estabilidade a constância
procrastinadores alguns o que nunca muda
masculina é a borda do rio fui foco
objetivo chegar lá masculina sempre
buscar acabar de concluir chegar no fim
infinitude é a busca eterna do masculino
porque os meninos se arriscam mais
porque eles andam na borda do muro
porque eles sobem na parede porque eles
falam pio quando a gente fala não quero
ver mais um pio
como fala na raiz do masculino
a gente tem a morte não é a morte
efetiva mas é uma amostra simbólica sem
procura o fim e aí a gente tem aqui
possibilidade de interpretação que são
diversas
ali no masculino a gente não tem o
pedido de ajuda pedir ajuda para um
homem geralmente é algo que se faz de um
homem para outro homem quando a gente
quando o cara admira muito
essa pessoa a gente no feminino nós
mulheres aliando a gente tem muito mais
facilidade de colaborar e melhorar a
gente se auxilia a gente tem na nossa
raiz acolher receberem twitter é
colaborar contribuir essa é a nossa raiz
do feminino
considerando tudo isso a gente comece a
acolher e trazer para a nossa nossas
relações mais do feminino porque se
amplia os campos de possibilidade de
todo mundo para os homens também o
panorama interno aqui e o panorama
interno aqui a gente está no feminino a
gente irradia vida a gente tá bem a
gente está no bem estar
geralmente quando a gente tá apaixonado
depois que a gente corre depois que a
gente fazia uma aula de obra a gente tá
uau não é mas o que é o panorama
masculina é um é um panorama de medo de
destruição quanto mais informação
colhida uma pessoa tá mais ela se
direciona para um fim
imagine o que é isso internamente
imagine isso no mundo que a gente vive
os homens ou masculino eles têm um
intrínseco medo de não cumprir e que se
espera de falharem de não darem conta de
não serem bons o suficiente isso tá lá
então o que acontece quando a gente
chega e fala eu faço com você meu filho
eu não da licença deixa eu faço
churrasco não sabe fazer direito seu
enquanto de nós fazemos isso vou contar
pra vocês uma história engraçada
aconteceu recentemente na minha casa eu
tenho dois filhos um menino de 5 uma
menina de sete estados da noite
todo mundo no domingo meu filho vai
pegar um copo de água pra ele na
geladeira com br
não pega um novo um copo de água da
semana já deitou né
é essa gata cansado de dormir e ele foi
lá pegou um outro copo com água de coco
e show pois no copo e saindo da cozinha
com os dois copos e ela chega ela pega
um copo na mão dele fala assim
finalmente você fez alguma coisa de útil
benjamin e eu fiquei com aquela cara
tipo na minha casa
o final dessa história mas quantos de
nós a gente não faz exatamente isso é
com as nossas crianças eu vira e mexe
vejo aí falando com um filho chamado de
cabeção dj ea gente talvez a gente não
se dê conta de que o panorama aqui
dentro já é suficiente então se a gente
talvez inserir mais de feminino em nós
mulheres e na nossa forma de atuação com
o masculino talvez a gente deseja uma
mudança de panorama
imaginem os homens que mandam no mundo
se eles tivessem mais empatia
acolhimento a possibilidade de sentir a
dor do outro não
só o lucro objetivo dinheiro né
o imagina que diferença desse mundo né
imagina e diferença o economista ano
passado ela fez uma matéria que foi
muito contundente eu trouxe dados só pra
gente ver o tamanho do poderia masculina
92.812 entre os presidentes e primeiros
ministros de países do mundo
são aulas 97% dos milionários feitos
alto feito self-made na lista da forbes
são homens e 95 por cento dos seus das
500 maiores empresas do mundo são homens
91% 91.495.660 é um dom muito masculina
imagine se a gente na nossa popularidade
na nossa possibilidade de exercício do
feminino consegue influenciar a colher
esses homens que muitos seria esse o
mundo mais inclusivo um mundo mais
colaborativa e a gente já está vendo
isso a gente já está vendo isso em
muitas iniciativas
agora como é que a gente sai dessa
cilada que a gente se meteu
a gente ficou de um lado eles ficaram do
outro é um outro a é um a que propõe que
a gente saia da depreciação e vai para
apreciação e depreciação é julgar
apontar o que não foi feito
vanessa contou uma história ótima de um
casal que ela não deixou a mulher não
deixava o cara mais fazer a mochila das
crianças porque ele sempre fazer nada e
ela sempre tinha que fazer de novo então
ela faz porque não quer ter o trabalho
de fazer afinal de contas ele é um
fíbula e isso não é apreciar isso não é
um poder são roque
volto a dizer se o universo do masculino
é um universo de receio de instituição e
intrinsecamente está rolando uma
conversa de eu não sou bom o suficiente
eu tenho que tomar muito cuidado para
não reforçar essas mensagens e se a
gente quer trazê los
esses poderosos estar junto para essa
conversa sobre feminismo sobre inclusão
sobre colaboração
a gente tem que usar o feminino empatia
acolhimento reforço do positivo não
reforço do que foi feito errado e
escárnio xingamento rebaixamento
isso é muito diferente do cenário de
apreciação que é um acolhimento a partir
de que a partir de agora vocês sabem
disso
alguém que está constantemente mudando
com o fim ea morte como é que vocês
receberiam guerreiro ensangüentado na
casa de vocês que vai atrás faltando
dinheiro o que vai atrás para fazer um
projeto
não estou falando só de marido e mulher
tá só toma muito cuidado com isso como a
gente acolhe como a gente faz andar a
acolher a fazer prosseguir para fazer
evoluir
eu sei que para nós mulheres a gente
perdeu esse tom mas isso é praticável
apreciação é do feminino acolhimento é
do feminina reconhecer o que já foi
confiado neste alguém diferente de fazer
por alguém confia
isso a gente faz não só com as crianças
mas como é que o reforço a confiança de
que ele pode ver que ele não é idiota
não precisa disso ea gente quando
reclama a gente disse isso claramente
você não é tão bom
eu faço pra você eu sou melhor que você
a gente está fazendo isso constantemente
ampliando e se há mesmo a elogiar e
admirar elogiar cada pequeno passo
porque a gente quer trazê los para a
conversa não é atacando não é separando
acolhendo e trazendo para o mesmo nível
isso vale pra nós em primeiro lugar que
só hoje é que houve várias mulheres
quando eu elogiei alguma coisa se a mas
eu comprei na última líquida baratinha
não é velho olha pra se a partir de um
ponto de admiração pelo que se é pelas
pequenas coisas que se consegue a eu não
consigo é também nessa tão burra é tão
ruim de matemática de finanças não
consigo nunca fazer isso para um
pouquinho ele está consciente reconhece
é de pequeno e eu sei que isso é uma
prática e
na prática assim como o dono dieta é
difícil a gente começar e eu sei também
que o cérebro precisa de uns 30 dias
para entender que algo aconteceu
então a minha proposta para vocês aqui
pra tudo isso se de gente além do
conhecimento que a gente acabou de ter a
gente pratique apreciação ea alta
apreciação
são pequenos gestos são pequenas coisas
mas que fazem a diferença como por
exemplo terminou essa história na minha
casa do meu amigo de o livro de eli é o
arranco copo na mão dele fala
finalmente você fez alguma coisa de útil
em janeiro e ele com aquela cara eu
falei mais filha ele foi lá pegou um
copo de água pra você gostou então que
tal conhecer
eu gostei muito
aí ele eu gostei que você conheceu ou
seja age e lógica é difícil né gente a
gente acha que ele tem obrigação é a
gente é complicado a gente está num
ponto na cabeça que a gente acha que ele
já tem que fazer é saber fazendo o que a
gente não tem que reconhecer e elogiar
porque afinal de contas é obrigação na
cabeça
é isso que a gente vem fazendo sempre dá
conta mas vou falar o benjamim ficou
muito mais gentil depois disso né sem
perder o machinho que ele é no bom
sentido né ele sente empoderado ele se
sente reconhecido ele tira mesmo
sozinhas mp fala muito é a mesma sem
ninguém pedir a cada filho e pega flores
etc etc
e eu acho que isso vem mudando muito a
minha forma de lidar com masculina que é
uma forma que eu encontrei de me curar
eu posso
obrigada